that a good choice for S equals 1 turns out to be a very bad choice for S equal 4 but assuming that we do know s in
advance and we choose T according to our specification then it turns out that Grover's algorithm will find a solution
with probability at least 1 - x over n and often it'll be much larger than that it's also at least s Over N but
that's actually much less interesting what's more interesting is that as the fraction s Over N gets small the bound
on the probability of success gets closer and closer to one now as I've already remarked several
times the number T represents not only the number of iterations of the grover operation we perform but also the number
of queries we're making so how does this number depend on s and
n first let's start with the fact that the inverse sign of X is always at least X provided that X is between Z and 1
that's pretty easy to show if you happen to know the tailor series for the inverse sign function but there are other ways to reason it and we're just
going to take this as given because it's true that means that Theta is at least the square root of s/
n and consequently T is at most < / 4 * the < TK of n /
s so that's actually even better than Big O of root n the larger s is in
comparison to n the fewer queries we need to make and in a way it's not surprising that this fraction shows up
like this given that its reciprocal defines Theta and at the end of the day Theta is really all that matters for
this analysis as we've just seen Grover's algorithm Works quite well when we know
in advance how many solutions there are but what if we don't know how many solutions there
are there's one pretty simple approach and that is to just choose the number of iterations
randomly and specifically choosing T uniformly at random between one and the floor of pi over 4 * root n turns out to
be a pretty good way to do this the upper end of this range is roughly the number of queries we would choose for Unique search and actually
it's exactly the right number in most cases this is when the angle Theta is as small as it can possibly be excluding
the trivial case when there aren't any solutions the idea here is that instead of carefully aiming our state Vector at
K A1 like we did when we knew how many solutions there were we're basically rotating by a random angle as if we're
just giving the state Vector a random spin if there happens to to be just one solution then our random spin could push
the state Vector close to K A1 but it might also just go part way there and if there happens to be many solutions then
our random spin could potentially send the state Vector around the circle multiple times so we don't expect this to reveal
a solution with a probability close to one but the chance that this leads to a solution if there is one turns out to be
pretty good it's always at least 40% in fact that's not obvious but it is the
case it certainly isn't shocking though because a truly random angle would have a 50% chance of finding a
solution anyway 40% is not bad and remember that we can always boost the probability of finding a solution by
repeating the process choosing T independently each time by doing this the chances of not
finding a solution when there is one decreases exponentially in the number of times we repeat so if we want a 99% %
chance to find a solution what we can do is to run this simple approach 10 times again with t chosen independently each
time naturally if we don't find a solution we output no Solutions if there aren't any solutions
we won't find one and so in that case we'll always output the correct answer which is no Solutions if there are solutions we
might fail to find one and incorrectly declare that there are no Solutions but the probability of that happening can be made very small
we also have as I mentioned a few moments ago that this requires a number of queries or evaluations of f that's Big O of root
n so using Grover's algorithm we can still solve the search problem with high probability with Big O of root end
queries even if we don't know in advance how many solutions there are there's also a more sophisticated
approach that can lead to a reduction in the number of queries as the number of solutions grows I won't describe it in
detail though and instead I'll just focus on the main idea we start with capital T being equal
to one we then run Grover's algorithm for a random number of iterations but where the upper bound is T so the first
time we get to step two we're going to run Grover's algorithm with one iteration but T is going to be
growing if we find a solution then we output that solution and we stop and if we don't find a solution we make t
larger and try again and at some point before T gets too large we'll terminate the process and
we'll declare that there aren't any solutions it's the same basic idea as we have in the simple approach where we're
giving the state Vector random spins essentially but here we're starting out with lighter spins first where T is
small just in case there are a lot of Solutions in this way we won't waste queries by making the state go around
and around the circle by spinning too hard but if it doesn't work meaning that we don't find a solution we try again
but we spin a little bit harder or potentially a little bit harder to make this work the rate of
increase of T has to be chosen carefully and one way to make it work is to replace T by the ceiling of 54s time T
So T is being increased exponentially and intuitively we can think about it as spinning 25% harder each
time and it's important for the analysis that t increases exponentially like this why 54s you might ask well it's
just a number that works and there's actually a range of values that work but two doesn't work for instance doubling T
each time is too fast of an increase to take full advantage of the benefits of lighter spins anyway the point of this more
sophisticated method is that it gives the same ASM totic bound on the number of queries we require as we had before
Big O of the square root of n / s but we don't don't need to know in advance how many solutions there are and by the way
we can stop this process when T gets to root n so if there aren't any solutions we'll reach that conclusion after bigo
of root end queries and that is how we can choose the number of iterations in Grover's algorithm to conclude the lesson I'll
make just a few brief remarks about Grover's algorithm first within the query model
Grover's algorithm is ASM totically optimal what what that means is that it's not possible to come up with a
query algorithm for solving the search problem or even the unique search problem specifically that uses ASM